[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction voici
et les titres de ce lundi 15 mai 2017
les proches d'adèle tué la semaine
dernière sur le parking d'un fast food
de plaisir demande à récupérer son corps
pour pouvoir l'enterrer selon les rites
musulmans
le juge n'a toujours pas accordé le
permis d'inhumer et ce en cas de demande
de contre-expertise lancé à chaque
printemps à travers la france
l'opération fermes ouvertes permettent
aux élèves âgés de 8 à 11 ans de
découvrir la vie à la ferme et le métier
d'agriculteur les images de l'opération
dans les yvelines à suivre et puis à
voisins le bretonneux vient de se tenir
le 1er championnat interclubs de combat
sportif et chorégraphie au sabre laser
evènement accompagné comme il se doit
d'une première convention retour de
l'univers star wars
la cyberattaque menée simultanément à
travers le monde vendredi dernier a
également touché les yvelines le
technocentre renault à guyancourt a été
la cible des hackers ce avec néanmoins
des conséquences moindres par rapport
aux autres sites industriels de
l'entreprise dont l'activité a parfois
été suspendu rappelons que le piratage
visait à demander une rançon pour éviter
blocage des ordinateurs ou divulgation
de données sensibles au moins une
dizaine d'entreprises françaises en plus
de renault ont été victimes de cette
cyberattaque qui a touché près de 150
pays l'actualité nous en parlions titre
c'est également la détresse de la
famille d'adèle premières victimes du
tireur originaire de trappes sur le
parking d'un fast food à plaisir devant
le commissariat de la commune les mines
étaient graves les visages fermés
vendredi soir une cinquantaine de
personnes demander la restitution du
corps afin de pouvoir l'enterrer au plus
vite
conformément aux rites de la religion
musulmane le reportage de stéphane
servant la famille d'adèle ghoul à 35
ans tuée de onze balles le 6 mai devant
un fast food de plaisir a organisé
vendredi soir un rassemblement devant le
commissariat de trappes pour réclamer le
droit de récupérer son corps et de
l'enterrer dignement
une cinquantaine de personnes ont
répondu à cet appel la mère de la
victime son frère sa soeur était présent
très douloureux c'est pour nous c'est
une double peine en fait voilà on a le
voilà on à l'assassinât de mon frère et
le fait est qu'on puisse pas récupéré
son corps et ne pas pouvoir voilà le
l'enterrer dignement et voilà de
d'essayer d'aller de l'avant et de dates
entre le juge n'a pas encore accordé le
permis d'inhumer
il peut décider de le faire après huit
jours voire plus cela suscite
l'incompréhension et la douleur de la
famille
un tueur toujours recherché et dangereux
on a peur on a peur pour voilà moi j'ai
peur pour les membres de ma famille on
reste cloîtré chez nous il a menacé au
passé
plusieurs membres de ma famille en
l'occurrence ma soeur ses proches ne
veulent pas attendre l'interpellation du
suspect avant de pouvoir enterrer adel
en tunisie l'homme recherché est
également suspecté d'avoir blessé deux
autres personnes attrapent ce lundi soir
une nouvelle manifestation a lieu devant
la mairie de trappes
la réponse du juge se fait toujours
attendre politique
à présent le président de la république
est à peine élu est dorénavant en
fonction la course pour les législatives
s'engagent les réunions publiques se
multiplient avant le premier tour prévu
je vous le rappelle le 11 juin
et c'est le cas dans la 10e
circonscription des yvelines le maire de
saint-arnaud jean claude husson candidat
du parti socialiste était à maurepas en
fin de semaine dernière haussmann
vendeurs des premières réunions
publiques pour le candidat ps
jean-claude husson à la mairie de
maurepas le but échanger avec le public
et surtout présenter son programme
il existe des marges de manoeuvre que
l'on doit mettre
en oeuvre pour réellement agir pour le
quotidien des français on ne peut pas
continuer avec une politique de
saupoudrage on veut tout faire à tout
moment
donc ce qui est important c'est d'abord
de définir des priorités
trois priorités 4 ou 5 et se concentrer
sur celle ci dans les yvelines benoît
hamon est arrivé cinquième au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle le
candidat que jean claude husson a
soutenu n'a récolté que 6 93% des voix
devancé par jean luc mélenchon un
résultat qui n'inquiète pas le maire de
saint-arnoult notre objectif c'est bien
évidemment de convaincre les habitants
de notre circonscription sur les valeurs
du parti socialiste sont au contraire
pour moi
une motivation que de convaincre ses
électeurs que le bon choix à gauche
c'est le parti socialiste et qui a
encore un avenir pour la partie spéciale
son but prendre la place du député
sortant jean-frédéric poisson à nouveau
candidat sur la 10e circonscription jean
claude husson fustige la politique menée
par l'élu du parti chrétien-démocrate
allés en syrie venir gêner la diplomatie
française qui est porté en premier lieu
par le président de la république et le
ministre des affaires des étrangères moi
je trouve ça assez extraordinaire sur la
cigale inscription je n'ai pas vu il est
dans comme beaucoup de députés dans une
politique de saupoudrage
on le voit aussi à travers l'utilisation
de sa réserve parlementaire
pas du tout comme ça que je vois le rôle
de député et jean claude husson continue
sa campagne prochaine réunion publique
pour le candidat ps mercredi prochain à
20h à la salle du colombier à
saint-arnoult ont quitté la politique
chaque printemps le syndicat agricole la
fnsea relance à travers la france son
opération fermes ouvertes une expérience
pédagogique pour les élèves de 8 à 11
ans élèves accompagnés de leurs
instituteurs et qui sont invités à
découvrir la vie à la ferme mais aussi
le métier d'agriculteur direction gambey
à présent avec stéphane servant
c'était une journée portes ouvertes dans
les fermes pour les élèves de primaire
organisée par la fnsea pour mieux faire
connaître les métiers de l'agriculture
et de l'élevage à des élèves souvent
citadins cette initiative on a enchanté
plus d'un comme des vaches
oui oui un cheval de chiens
des veaux et un taureau lui classe en
plein air pour la journée avec déjeuner
et cour de récréation un peu spécial
l'occasion aussi pour la nouvelle
présidente de la fnsea de rappeler
l'attachement du monde agricole à une
production de qualité respectueuse de
l'environnement est proche des
consommateurs
mais cela a un prix vous aurez pas des
prairies de ce type là des animaux de ce
type là s'il n'y a pas la clé des prix
rémunérateur pour les producteurs c'est
un tout et désormais les consommateurs
souhaitent mieux connaître l'origine des
produits qu'ils achètent ils n'hésitent
plus à venir acheter directement à la
ferme leur viande comme chez cet éleveur
qui a près de 150 bovins
ils savent comment je travaille ils
voient comment nourrir les animaux
ils sont nés à la ferme ils sont
ils passent toute leur vie sur
l'exploitation à manger de l'herbe du
foin et cetera l'hiver etc
ils savent comment ils sont élevés et
nourris une journée pour changer un peu
l'image d'un monde agricole en pleine
mutation
les agriculteurs souhaitent désormais
avec ces nouveaux ambassadeurs se
rapprocher des consommateurs soucieux de
transparence de traçabilité et de
qualité d'autres journées portes
ouvertes sont déjà prévus
après le monde agricole celui de star
wars changement de registre c'était la
guerre des étoiles ce week end à voisins
le bretonneux le gymnase les pyramides a
accueilli le premier championnat
interclubs de combat au sabre laser le
temps d'une journée chevalier jedi
stormtrooper se sont côtoyés avant de
repartir combat à travers d'autres
galaxies nicolas landry pour les images
le commentaire est signé mélanie poker
des combats âpres pour faire gagner le
bien vains jedi se sont affrontés à
voisins le bretonneux pour repousser les
forces du mal l'objectif de ce premier
championnat interclubs de sabre laser le
combat sportif au sabre laser
c'est un combat la touche 15 points
gagnés en trois minutes donc avec des
règles spécifiques on a créé dont
combats ont dîné en individuel on ne
peut pas utiliser les pouvoirs de la
force
par contre effectivement dans le combat
en équipe là on va pouvoir s'amuser à
pouvoir lancer des pouvoirs comme des
éclairs de force hors de nombreuses
forces en présences ou les stratégies se
penche longuement tout ça sous la
vigilance des soldats de l'armée
impériale aux patrons contrôle au matin
à l'ordre mal à trouver des jedi des
rebelles on a fait quelques arrestations
et je reste à voir quand j'étais petit
j'avais 7 ans le l'épisode iv au cinéma
et ben voila je tombé dedans quand
j'étais petit est trompeur
même si c'est les méchants ça une scène
qu'à leur passé c'est emblématique les
jedi ont ramené l'equilibre dans la
force prochain combat le 13 décembre
2017 avec la sortie de l'épisode 8 et on
poursuit ce journal avec la fête de la
petite enfance était à trappes également
ce week-end les cinq lieux et d'accueil
des enfants de 1 à 3 ans ont présenté
leur mode de fonctionnement aux parents
ambiance avec nicolas gandrille et taïna
deux ans et demi et louane trois ans
sont venus avec leurs mamans elles ont
pu s'amuser sur différents stands des
activités proposées par les auxiliaire
puériculture de trappe lors de la fête
de la petite enfance c'est pour
découvrir les activités
qui a autour et puis quelqu'un rencontre
aussi ses petits amis de la crèche
puisqu elle à la crèche collective et ça
nous a permis de découvrir en fait des
petits ateliers
notamment au niveau de la nourriture la
propreté
et puis là au niveau de la motricité je
suis venu parce que pour ma fille en
fait
pour qu'elles s'amusent comme je l'avais
écrite et de l'activité pour les enfants
pour moi c'est l'idéal pour un rendez
vous destiné aussi aux futurs parents
sahara et alain attendent un enfant au
mois d'août ils viennent chercher des
informations notamment sur les
différentes structures d'accueil attrape
moi beaucoup de questions au niveau du
mode de garde
parce que quand on travaille on était
assez stressés sur comment va placer
l'enfant quand voilà comment fonctionne
une crèche
la vie de l'enfant dans la crèche
l'objectif c'était de montrer comment on
entre par année en femme on peut
partager des choses
en s'appuyant sur ce qu'on peut vivre
dans les établissements là et puis aussi
d'expliquer aux nouveaux parents comment
ça se passe dans les structures ce
qu'ils peuvent y trouver rencontrer des
équipes est rassuré un moyen de pouvoir
répondre aux questions des parents une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine et pour refermer ce
journal les images du vide greniers de
montigny le bretonneux installé comme il
se doit sur l'avenue nicolas bour
dimanche dernier le 14 mai des centaines
de personnes se laisser aller on
trouvait bien évidemment des vêtements
ou encore des jouets l'occasion pour
quelques brocanteurs de passer à un
moment convivial voici quelques
impressions
je suis venu aujourd'hui parce que
j'avais beaucoup de choses dans la cave
dont je voulais me débarrasser et que
mon ami m'a proposé de l'accompagner
s'est passé une bonne journée en famille
comme on fait chaque année
ça nous permet de nous rapprocher et
puis nous ressasser des souvenirs de
voir les choses car à quintin rappel de
ces choses là puis voilà que tout
simplement on a un petit peu de tout
c'est et c'est aussi prendre pour se
débarrasser des des choses qu'on est
entassé à la maison et puis donc je le
fais avec ma maman et ma soeur donc
c'est aussi pour se retrouver toutes les
trois c'est un plaisir les replays sont
à consulter sur notre site internet et
sur notre application mobile merci
d'avoir suivi ce journal les programmes
se poursuivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]